I think to try and compare what Hitler  and the Nazis did the millions of people  who died the Holocaust to the free  democracies of Europe coming together to  trade and to cooperate and in the  process to help secure peace on the  continent of Europe is frankly deeply  offensive there's no neutrals in this  debate from the moment that the prime  minister decided to turn the government  into a campaigning organisation he's  part of a party which is very you're a  file in the House of Commons I'm sure he  doesn't feel he can take on too many  different battles of bunce and I think  that he's there for got along with the  sentiments of his colleagues  I do think his calculation to support  leaving was as much to do about him  being the Future Leaders the toy party  as as thinking about the future of the  company